[Music]
young people do come up to me sometimes
and they'll be like um what should we do
like like sometimes little girls will
come up to me and say i want to act and
how did you get into it and how should i
do it and i know it sounds cheesy but i
always tell them like you gotta do what
actually feels good to you like you
gotta be yourself you can't change
yourself to try to get a part or
something like you have to be you and
you have to feel good about it and i
think that took me a while to learn just
because when you start auditioning at a
really young age and you're pretending
to be all these different characters and
you're trying to get parts and things
that can kind of make it hard to figure
out even harder i think to figure out
exactly who you are so yeah i'd say just
always like follow your instincts your
gut instincts
and really listen to your heart even
though that does sound cheesy it's
totally true
if a line you're saying or something
doesn't feel right it probably you're
probably right and trust your instinct
because when i was little so many times
people around me would be like no it's
turning out good but i'd feel kind of
weird about it and then later when i
would see it on tv i'd be like no i
could have definitely done that better
so
yeah i think just really trust your gut
um and it's good to have people around
you that you also trust to give you
their advice but in the end i feel like
you have to really believe that what
you're doing is good for it to turn out
right i've stayed true to the brand
because i'm staying true to myself so
that means like if i am changing and if
my life is changing and my beliefs are
changing or my interests are changing
then the show is going to evolve with me
i think that sometimes creators have a
hard time if they're stuck and
pigeonholed into like their with a
younger demographic they sometimes feel
like they can't age my daddy gang my
daddy gang my listeners they have grown
up with me it feels like and so it
wouldn't be natural for me to continue
to talk about something that happened in
college i'm 27 now and so i think the
evolution of call her daddy is just
what's happening in my life because i
know everyone else is also going through
that process of aging and growing up i
am so specific when it comes to my
collaborations i have so many names
thrown at me every day and it's been
really a learning process
i'm so grateful for every interview that
i've done i just started interviewing
last year so i was like well first of
all how do i interview like what do i do
how do i interview anyone and then i
think i started to recognize everyone
has a story just like me and i want to
make sure that i'm giving my platform
the space for people to come on and feel
so comfortable so confident and safe to
sit down with me and tell their story
because i know there's millions of
people that are listening that will be
able to find something they relate to
even if it's a miley cyrus and it's like
i can't relate to miley cyrus and
they're like oh
yes i can or someone that's another
podcaster that you may not know and
giving them the platform to be like hey
this is my story and then millions of
people writing in being like thank you
for opening up and being vulnerable i
relate you cannot try to copy everyone i
think there's such an oversaturation
right now with regard to media and
everyone that's trying to create thinks
oh well i saw this working let me do my
own twist on it the reason i truly
believe call her daddy became successful
of course the content was
chef's kiss but it was also the behind
the scenes that i tried to not talk
about was the amount of editing that
went into this process no one was doing
that for a podcast so like i was trying
to create a product that a millennial or
a gen z would hear and it's like oh my
god this is so entertaining well most
podcasts are slow and you may fall
asleep not call her daddy so i was i
think the the advice would be you have
to
go with your gut on what you are
passionate about but do not copy others
because it's not going to flourish and
it's not going to thrive if it's also
not just genuinely what you are creating
like don't copy someone do what you
envision yourself when you're first
starting it feels i guess like the whole
world is against you right you go up
against every problem you could imagine
it's almost like
this one quote that resonates the most
is like it's like chewing glass every
day looking out in the abyss just hoping
for the sunlight but persistence is key
again if you have the drive you're going
to see the opportunities and you just
take those opportunities as they come
and eventually things pan out
at the beginning it doesn't you don't
have this painted picture that of what
it's going to end up like when i first
started it i didn't have this painted
picture that i was going to be at where
it is today
when i started it i started with my own
money i wasn't abreast to the silicon
valley tech scene
i didn't know the investors this is my
first rodeo
and i just figured it out as i went
because i again i had the drive and i
saw every opportunity possible and i was
able to pull in so many great people in
the beginning they really helped pull it
to where it is today just through the my
drive and persistence so i had been
doing uh video games posting content for
about three years while still going to
school and still playing basketball but
it was never really a career at the time
so it got to a point where
i was making pretty good money and i
wasn't really happy going to school so i
asked my parents i said yo can i take
off a half a semester really see if i
can make this thing a career and they
said okay and they let me do a half a
semester off i focus a lot on gaming and
then the rest was kind of history it
just kind of took off from there a lot
of people think to be a gamer you have
to have like this most fancy equipment
you know have to be all these tools and
in reality i started with like a 50 inch
tv in a garage with no air conditioning
on the lowest of low quality setups you
know especially now with technology how
kids can have you know the new xbox a
new playstation and it's uh it's
encouraging people that you don't really
need a fancy computer you don't need a
lot of
gadgets there's a lot of expensive
things
if you love gaming if you love just
creating content and overall just like i
said being a gamer
definitely a career path and that's what
i try to encourage people is that you
know you don't need a lot to get started
with this being
out there in the public a lot for gaming
has uh meant a lot to me as far as like
you know pushing diversity in the space
and kind of encouraging um other you
know black gamers like this is a career
path that you can chase you know what
i'm saying so it's not you don't have to
be just an athlete or rapper like gaming
is an actual career path that you can
choose if you want to so i think that's
one of the biggest things is i just
pushing diversity if there was a new
artist
you know i would just encourage them to
really try and tell the truth in their
music and that seems like a no-brainer
but when i say tell the truth i just
mean
it goes a long way to just be vulnerable
and speak from the heart i think that's
what keeps you here if you look at all
the artists that have been here for a
decade or longer and
haven't just gone to the wayside
they're all truth tellers and they all
speak from here and it doesn't mean
don't make the party music got to make
some of that too
but at some point people have to sit
down and feel like i know who he is or
she is
i know who that is because there's a lot
of artists out here that
they fizzle out
because there was just simply a
character to enjoy for a second or they
were just making music for the moment
and you never found out who they were in
the heart
there's even big artists have big songs
that
maybe they can't tour
because they can't sell tickets because
no one is attached to who they are as a
person
so if you give pieces of yourself to
your fans
it goes a long way
so that would be my biggest advice is
don't forget to um
be vulnerable if you can